[Musique]
et notre invité politique se maintenant
c'est fait monsieur guérini bonjour
jouer aussi mon coup d'être avec nominé
c'est la transformation et de la
fonction publique et vous avez laissé
suis quand même votre place à la tête
d'une arche qui est devenu renaissance à
stéphane ces journées on va bien sûr
parler de tout ça on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre aux
dons boulot fabrice beaux jours
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france à commencer par la réforme des
retraites puisque vous avez sans doute
lu cette interview de françois bayrou
stanislas guérini qui dit que la réforme
des retraites ne peut se faire au détour
d'un amendement dans le budget de la
sécurité sociale je le cite je suis
opposé au passage en force si on se
lance dans cette voie là alors nous
sommes en train de coaliser d'abord les
oppositions entre elles puis de diviser
la société française au niveau ben moi
je dis que cette réforme allait
nécessaire et je crois qu'à d'ailleurs
aucune ambiguïté là dessus dans la
majorité
et au fond dans une grande part de
l'opinion du pays je pense que on
ressent bien qui a besoin de travailler
plus davantage le volume de travail dans
le pays soit plus important pour pouvoir
financer des progrès pour pouvoir
financer aussi faire face à des
évolutions à des transitions je pense
notamment à transition démographique
donc la méthode posons ce à la façon
indiscutable n'y a aucune ambiguïté là
dessus ensuite il ya différentes
possibilités de méthode qui s'ouvre à
nous moi je suis ministre du
gouvernement pas ministre en charge des
retraites j'ai pas à m'exprimer sur le
choix de le faire dans le plfss l'année
prochaine dans un projet de loi haddock
ça n'est pas ma décision
un ministre du travail en charge de la
réforme des retraites reçoit aujourd'hui
les organisations syndicales je suis
absolument certain qu'il aura l'occasion
d'avoir des discutions de recueillir les
avis des uns et les autres à la fois sur
le fond et sur la méthode c'est à lui de
conduire cd 106 est un styliste du
gouvernement de rendre des arbitrages
sur la bonne méthode pour le faire pour
éviter la transformation et la majorité
ouais je pense que d'ici l'examen du
budget puisque la question vous poser
concerne l'examen du budget je pense
qu'il y aura une clarté sur la façon
d'avancer c'est le 26 effectivement que
le budget présenté sur la façon
d'avancer encore une fois moi j'ai un
avis extrêmement clair extrêmement
nettes sur le fait que nous avons besoin
pour financer les progrès de faire cette
réforme des retraites maintenant qu'elle
est oui bien sûr bien sûr à la fois
parce que le système de retraites
lui-même montre un déséquilibre durable
jouable parfois des débats sur cette
question là on peut le prendre dans tous
les sens notre système de retraite
aujourd'hui et plus encore demain montre
un déséquilibre donc nous allons pouvoir
de le faire mais nous avons besoin de le
faire davantage encore parce que nous
sommes un pays où nous travaillons moins
tant que les autres pays européens et
les autres pays de s'aider eux et pour
autant notre modèle social et plus
protecteurs et bien si nous voulons
répondre à cette équation là c'est à
dire continuer à investir dans notre
modèle social alors oui nous avons
absolument besoin de faire ça très bien
le faire en début de quinquennat
j'imagine est ce que pour vous ce n'est
pas un petit peu l'épreuve du feu sur ce
début de deuxième quinquennat c'est
l'épreuve test mais voyageant je le vois
pas comme vous l'indiquez c'est à dire
au fond comme une forme d'affrontement
de capacité à imposer des choses cet
arrondi parfois début de quinquennat
dans un sens où si l'on n'arrive plus à
faire passer des réformes c'est une
réforme qu'il faut faire le plus
rapidement possible parce que c'est
maintenant que nous avons besoin de
financer des avancées pour concitoyens
vision et divise les syndicats mais je
vivais un agent est très bien mais si on
veut la faire de la façon la plus
consensuelle possible la façon la moins
brutale possible c'est à dire la façon
la moins immédiate possible alors il
faut se donner des marges pour avoir une
progressivité c'est d'ailleurs ce que le
président de la république avait indiqué
pendant sa campagne on n'avait pas
passer du jour au lendemain en
augmentant de plusieurs années l'âge de
départ à la retraite on veut le faire
progressivement quelques mois par an
c'était quatre mois par an qu'avait
indiqué le président de la république
donc tout ceci nécessite d'avoir la
discussion le plus tôt possible pour
pouvoir justement offrir cette
progressivité et avoir la réforme la
moins brutale possible mais ça se
discute évidemment en concertation avec
les organisations syndicales et c'est ce
que olivet du soft
aujourd'hui
mais bon encore une fois je ne vais pas
vous donner une opinion tant que
ministre gouvernement qui n'est pas en
charge du dossier sur ce ne serait pas
quand même contradictoire avec le
conseil national de la refondation lancé
la semaine dernière
non parce que je crois se sont pas les
mêmes sujets et d'ailleurs en conclusion
du conseil national de la fondation de
président de la république a d'une
certaine façon classer les sujets la 10è
certains sujets qui sont dans l'agenda
gouvernemental et c'est bien légitime et
c'est bien normal il ya une élection
d'ailleurs les choses ont été présentés
très clairement pendant cette élection
et puis on sent bien qu'il ya des sujets
qui nécessitent d'avoir des discussions
au sein du conseil national la
refondation passe que par nature et sont
plus transversaux je pense à la question
de la transition démographique la
question de la transition numérique
l'évolution du travail logement qu est
un sujet que les participants au cnr ont
décidé de remettre sur la table et donc
si on fait ce distinguo là alors on peut
avancer dans l'agenda tel qu'il était
prévu et puis il ya des sujets qui
nécessitent peut-être d discuté hors les
murs de l'assemblée nationale pour être
préparés mature et pour avoir aussi une
forme de créativité dans la discussion
parce que ce sont les grands défis du
pays et qu'on a
pour ça voyez ces deux natures des
journées parlementaires qui ne sont pas
venus au conseil national de la
refondation à part évidemment les
parlementaires de la majorité vous le
regrettez voit surtout jeu j'ai bon
espoir que chacun puisse rejoindre la
taille la table du concerné ça la
refondation ça sincèrement je crois que
ceux qui ont participé
peuvent témoigner du fait qui s'est
passé quelque chose au conseil national
lors aux fondations dans cette première
journée au moins de nature à la fois
peut-être parce que les débats n'étaient
au fonds passent sous l'oeil des caméras
j'assume de le dire et c'est sur un
plateau de télévision mais parfois ça
aide à sortir des postures et puis parce
que chacun est sorti de son couloir de
nage voyez au début de la journée
d'ailleurs c'était assez intéressant
voyez que les uns et les autres venez
avec les propositions qui portent depuis
des années dans leurs associations
d'élus dans leur domaine font de
compétences et puis au fur et à mesure
des discussions on a vu que il était ô
combien nécessaire dans le pays qu'on
puisse de temps en temps sortir un petit
peu décloisonner les sujets les uns avec
les autres et là on avait des
discussions les plus intéressantes qui
soit je crois vraiment sincèrement que
ce sco ressenti les participants ouais
je le disais au début samedi soir vous
avez passé la main à la tête dans marche
devenu renaissance le parti de la
majorité présidentielle le parti
présidentiel en tout cas stéphane
séjourné renaissance qui s'est donc
construit sans horizon le parti
d'edouard philippe et sans modem le
parti de françois bayrou comme ça qu'on
avait prévu de le faire depuis le début
effectif mans pour vous souhaitiez quand
même réunir la majorité sous une
bannière commune ensemble est ce que
finalement c'est le cas ce n'est ce
n'est pas un échec à roche croit
vraiment en de savoie edouard philippe a
dit entendre sa voix avant l'élection
présidentielle nous avions annoncée et
la création d'ensembles qui est
justement la fédération mais ça tient en
trois parties qui constituent la
majorité mais oui bien entendu
avec horizons avec le modem et puis avec
ce troisième pilier progressiste qui est
constituée par le parti présidentiel
renaissance et donc faire renaissance
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas détricoter
ensemble et c'est évidemment j'ai mis
suffisamment d'énergie dans le premier
quinquennat pour créer de l'unité dans
la majorité présentielle créer ce climat
de confiance qui je crois a porté ses
fruits dans ce premier quinquennat on
pas aujourd'hui
aller dans une situation serait en train
de détricoter ce qu'on avait fait dans
le précédent quinquennat donc non non on
continue ensemble justement et nous
fondons dans cette fédération des partis
de la majorité un parti présidentiel
s'appelle renaissance calé base élargie
par rapport à la république en marche
qui a vocation à rassembler aussi les
adhérents des partis agir venue du
centre-droit territoire de progrès venu
centre gauche centre gauche pour
continuer ce travail de dépassement dans
l'adn de ce qu'on avait fait en 2017
mais dans un mouvement supplémentaire
qui vient l'amplifier aujourd'hui ce qui
joue c est ce que ce qui je sais pas
justement l'investiture d'un candidat
pendant quatre ans on vous dit
d'ailleurs pas très satisfait de ce qui
se passe actuellement sur les cli
querelles les jeux qui déjà se
positionne pour dans quatre ans vous ce
serait trop tôt trop
je suis content latéral pas totalisant
faut voir des choses directement est
d'autant plus que je me suis exprimé
samedi soir j'ai parlé comme ça parce
que je pense qu'il faut pas éviter ce
type de sujet en disant tu as dès que
quelqu'un à faire un pas dans un sens ou
dans l'autre que ce soit au sein de
renaissance que ce soit côté ça va tout
de suite déclenché une salle de 10
artistes en disant que l'un faire loupé
à se re naissance l'autre ne pense qu'à
27 etc moi je vois tout ça ce que je
considère ces qui a toujours que deux
choix possibles faire le choix de la
confiance faire le choix la défiance
exactement ce que j'ai dit au samedi
soir le choix de la défense on connaît
bien le résultat généralement ça se
termine par des défaites à la fin parce
que on ne réussit pas le quinquennat
dont on a la charge et ce qui est au
fond le plus important choix de la
confiance il est plus exigeant et
nécessitent d'y mettre beaucoup
d'énergie je crois que c'est le seul
choix possible et moi très sincèrement
très sincèrement j'y crois
des personnalités fortes de la majorité
présidentielle dans renaissance dans
notre majorité présentielle d'ensemble
que ça n'est pas un problème ça n'est
pas un problème d'avoir des
personnalités qui ont du poids qui ont
des ambitions pour le pays d'autant que
de toutes mes discussions avec ces
personnalités là je vois que chacun est
conscient d'une chose on a besoin
d'abord de réussir ce quinquennat n'y
aura pas d' horizons de temps pas de
perspectives possibles pour 2027 si
collectivement si ensemble on ne réussit
pas le canada continue à cannes jean 27
un dernier mot là dessus et ça doit être
un candidat renaissance ont un candidat
ensemble est-ce qu'aujourd'hui votre
candidat naturel ce n'est pas encore
fini ça sera pour moi quand des traits
qui sera issu de la majorité
présidentielle n'ont pas forcément d'une
hes d'évidence renaissance a vocation à
avoir un candidat à soutenir un candidat
mais ça peut être y compris le même que
les autres partis de la majorité
présidentielle ne nous ne nous faites
vous faites pas de noeuds au cerveau
c'est mon souhait est absolue quand on a
créé ensemble nous avions dit que nous
préparions des grandes sélections
nationales du pays ensemble justement
avec les partenaires de la majorité
présentielle là aussi c'est pour moi une
forme d'évidence mais ça va on a dit les
choses très clairement entré en
renaissance on a indiqué que le parti
présidentiel avait vocation à désigner
un candidat à la présidentielle et c'est
bien normal mais nous avons dit aussi
que ce mode de désignation nous le
ferions collectivement après les
élections européennes très sincèrement
ça me semble le bon calendrier pour
faire ça skt renaissance
créer renaissance n'est pas actée aussi
que la république en marche a été ramené
en échec quel bilan vous faites vous
je crois que si la république en marche
n'avait pas existé n'avait pas fait le
travail que ce parti ce grand mouvement
citoyen a fait dans le premier cas
n'aurait pas pu créer renaissance
d'ailleurs ça ne nous oppose pas les uns
les autres au sein de cet ensemble là je
crois que la question du bilan si il ya
eu d'abord des grandes réussites
collectives
vous savez moi j'étais à la tête d'un
parti qui a le vrai à sa place pour
permettre pour faciliter la réélection
du président de la république ce n'est
pas anodin ça n'était pas arrivé sous la
vème république en dehors des périodes
de cohabitation donc c'est bien la
preuve que tout n'a pas raté des grands
moments de réussite il ya eu des
réussites aussi je dirais collective en
accompagnant des profils des parcours
quand je vois aujourd'hui le groupe
renaissance il est constitué de
référents de collaborateurs d'élus
locaux qu'ils avaient rejoint tout ça
aussi c'est le fruit d'un travail
collectif et puis bien sûr en tout bidon
il ya aussi des échecs moi je le dis
sans détour j'aurais aimé amener plus de
victoires à la majorité présentielle
dans les élections intermédiaires et une
défaite aux élections locales j'aurais
voulu qu'on on puisse franchir cette
étape là d'implantation plus rapidement
faut les regarder en face faut en tirer
les enseignements mois ya un
enseignement que je tire c'est que nous
devons préparer plus en amont les
élections locales vous le savez très
bien ici quand il s'agit du mandat de
maire je crois que les électeurs ne le
confirme pas quelqu'un qui se lancent
six mois avant dans la course il faut
travailler il faut gagner une forme de
légitimité locale quotidienne tout
connaître connaître au fond tous les
habitants de la ville pour pouvoir se
lancer ben c'est ce que on va s'attacher
à faire
on disait c'est pas à moi de fixer ses
objectifs et en le camp je je je n'ai
pas fait ce travail de préparation on
nous disait un peu la même chose avant
les dernières sénatoriales je constate
que tout le monde disait maintient le
groupe la majorité présentielle va
balayer va disparaître il a fait mieux
que ça il a même un peu progressé s'est
renforcée c'est le fruit je crois d'un
travail minutieux
dépassant parfois les étiquettes
partisanes je pense que c'est comme ça
qu'on doit préparer les élections
sénatoriales ben c'est comme ça qu'il
faut le faire aussi pour 2023
je pense qu'il faut voir ce qu'ils ont
envie de travailler avec la majorité
présidentielle
c'est comme ça qu'on avait un prix
forcément oui
mais vous savez quand on se rapproche du
terrain ces étiquettes là elles ont
tendance assez naturellement à
s'estomper un tout petit peu et moi ce
que je constate c'est que les sénateurs
eux mêmes en campagne sur le terrain ils
le font rarement avec l'étiquette d'un
parti politique ils le font avec leur
propre parcours leur propre ancrage leur
propre volonté de travailler ou pas eu
de la majorité présidentielle et ça
permet de mener un travail intelligent
généralement et oui on poursuit sur
l'opposition week-end difficile pour
adrien cnas de la france un soubie delà
du ps suite à des violences conjugales
qui d'ailleurs reconnu il a annoncé
prendre du recul par rapport à ses
fonctions à la nuque dont il est
coordinateur qu'elle est aujourd'hui
important c'est vous d'abord que c'est
une bonne décision qu'il a prise de se
mettre en retrait et doit-il
démissionner de ses mandats légaux
nécessaires l'a
reconnu des faits de violence sur sur sa
conjointe
nécessaire de prendre cette cette
décision moi j'ai pas envie de commenter
plus en avant politiquement les césures
la faute aux femmes c'est une cause
nationale mais bien entendu quand
endurant que mini sens tant qu'élu vous
réagissez cela est ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin ce qui doit démissionner moi
je je je je n'ai pas envie de m'exprimer
plus en avant n'a reconnu se fait
violence n'a attiré des conséquences
politiques avoue le saluer maintenant
oui je crois que c'était absolument
nécessaire
maintenant moi je n'ai jamais envie
d'être jeu la place des juges et même en
l'occurrence je vois dans la vie
politique il ya plein de gens qui sont
généralement candidat à être jugé a
passé juge et même juge à la place des
victimes puisque j'ai constaté que les
pousses d'adrien 4 nages elle même n'est
pas souhaitée la médiatisation de cette
affaire n'avait pas souhaité qui est des
suites qui lui soit donnée donc je veux
respecter ça aussi je pense que c'est
une façon de respecter aussi les
victimes que d'entendre cela je crois
jean luc mélenchon apporter un soutien
amical adrien kate moss il a parlé de
malveillance policière et de voyeurisme
médiatique je lui laisse ses propos
c'est sa responsabilité que de dire ça
fait le constat qu'il a tweeté puis re
tweeté c'est peut-être le signe qu'ils
n'étaient pas totalement à l'aise avec
ce qu'il avait pu dire sont des affaires
qui sont très délicates ouais j'ai dit
les choses comme je les ressentais ce
matin je n'ai pas envie de commenter
plus en à peine un mois sur le cumul des
mandats puisque karl olive qui est
député de la majorité présidentielle
remet le débat sur la table il souhaite
un retour au cumul des mandats il va
déposer un texte en ce sens soit êtes
fort je pense que c'est pas un débat qui
est indigne attends moi petit personnage
non je suis pas favorable à ça je crois
qu'on on apporter dans quinquennat
précédent
le dd mesure justement ne plus avoir le
cumul des mandats je suis pas très
certain que ça serait bien perçue par
l'opinion publique même si en tant
qu'ancien maire je respecte ça et je
peux comprendre qui est une volonté
d'avancer cette question là mais en tout
cas personnel moi je ne suis pas
favorable à l'immigration emmanuel
macron a indiqué qu'il pensait que
c'était une bonne chose de répartir les
étrangers sur l'ensemble du territoire
et notamment des territoires ruraux
c'est une pour une solution efficace ont
pu fermer les écoles maintenir un
service postal et c'est en tout cas je
pense que c'est oui bien sûr une forme
de de bon sens que de pouvoir le faire
c'est un mouvement qu'on essaye de
porter depuis quelques années cette
discussion que nous avions eue quand
gérard collomb était ministre de
l'intérieur quand examiné un projet de
loi là dessus je pense que il faut à
nouveau peut-être réfléchir aux outils
qui sont les nôtres pour mieux
accueillir et mieux intégrer les
populations auxquels nous donnons
l'asile puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit en l'occurrence donc je crois
qu'il faut continuer à travailler parce
que le constat il faut le regarder
lucidement c'est que nous avons à la
fois des difficultés pour faire
appliquer les décisions qui sont prises
de reconduite à la frontière en
l'occurrence est encore et toujours pour
bien intégrer les populations qui
viennent et en l'occurrence légitimement
sur notre sol et auxquels nous faisons
choix de donner l'asile donc résultat
bien sûr à raison avec le musée
intérieur de continuer à travailler sur
ces sujets là parce que son sujet sont
très importants et qui seront très
importants dans les années qui viennent
les mouvements de population aujourd'hui
dans le monde sont certainement moins
importants qui ne seront demain sous
beaucoup d'effet le réchauffement
climatique en étant
force de proposition c'est de répartir
les étrangers elle a réagi à son
discours de rentrée elle parle de mépris
pour les élus locaux et de négation de
l'identité des communes qu'est ce que
vous répondez à sa marine le pen comme
toujours elle ne s'intéresse à la
solution donc dès lors que vous voyez
une solution qui pointe son nez
son jeu à l aide le plus rapidement
possible prendre un grand marteau et lui
taper dessus parce que à chaque fois que
l'on fera avancer de façon pragmatique
de façon concrète des sujets à chaque
fois qu'on trouvera des solutions c'est
son fond de commerce à elle qui va
s'amoindrir d'autres sa réaction ne me
surprend pas tellement
énergétique puisque le gouvernement a
demandé aux ménages et aux entreprises
faire des économies d'énergie 10 %
qu'elles peuvent apprendre la fonction
publique n'est pas exactement celle là
commençait à travers le plan de sobriété
par réduire et 10% c'est bien l'objectif
que nous nous sommes fixés et ensuite
continuer dans cette voie de la
planification écologique je pense qu'il
faut jamais opposé le sujet sobriété
c'est à dire trouver des solutions de
court terme parce que on a un sujet de
souveraineté n'est rejeté de difficultés
d'approvisionnement pour toutes les
raisons que vous connaissez
l'objectif plus durable de bâtir une
société d carbone donc on va le faire en
activant tous les leviers possibles
sur le travail des agents ne s'est pas
très bien passé
maître aucune piste sous le tapis et je
pense qu'on doit tout étudier mais tout
discuté avec les organisations
syndicales
mais bien entendu d'ailleurs sur cette
question là j'ai l'occasion de beaucoup
ont discuté avec les organisations
syndicales j'étais avec elle jeudi
dernier j'ai réuni l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales on a abordé
aussi même c'était pas le coeur de nos
discussions ces questions là et j'ai dit
les choses et je crois pas que c'était
un point de conflit entre nous la
question du télétravail elle lie à
l'organisation du travail
moi je vais être extrêmement clair je
pense pas qu'on puisse appliquer dans un
plan de télétravail
sans que ce soit mise en discussion avec
l'ensemble des services on voit bien ce
sont des questions qui nécessitent une
discussion au plus près du terrain c'est
comme ça que l'on pourra avancer mais en
tout cas on va continuer à la fois sur
les questions de bâti nous avons pris la
décision d'accélérer encore les
investissements dans la rénovation du
bâti sa part fois c'est une chaudière
voyez qu on vient rénover ont fait des
grosses économies d'énergie j'étais dans
une cité administrative
on a connecté au réseau sauvage de ville
on diminue de 80% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et la consommation
énergétique et la facture donc on a
intérêt à pouvoir faire ça ça va
jusqu'aux mobilité au parc de véhicules
automobiles dans les administrations ce
sont toutes ces questions là qu'on a mis
en discussion et que nous présenterons
début octobre parce que je crois que
c'est très important que la puissance
publique que l'état commence par elle
même si on veut être entendu de nos
concitoyens si on veut être convaincant
pour qu'on puisse chacun d'entre nous
faire ces efforts là alors c'est
extrêmement important que l'état soit
exemplaire avance c'est exactement ce
que nous sommes en train de sur la
question de l'inflation il ya une
revalorisation des salaires dans la
fonction publique de trois et demi pour
cent est ce que d'autres hausses sont
prévues mais c'était l'objet des
discussions où j'avais avec les
organisations syndicales je leur ai dit
et pas de clause de revoyure
on n'a pas prévu une réelle augmentation
une nouvelle augmentation du point
d'indicé je fais remarquer que cette
augmentation là quand on vient là ajouté
aux augmentations moyennes dans la
fonction publique elle correspond
puisque cela correspond à 5 % au niveau
de l'inflation telle que l'insee la
mesure est là prévoit pour l'année 2022
dans son ensemble 5 3% ce sont les
prévisions de l'insee donc je crois que
la réponse de l'état employeur ou de la
puissance publique employeur a été à la
hauteur
un grand chantier qui suit
l'attractivité qu'on va évidemment
poursuivre et on aura l'occasion de se
revoir avec les organisations syndicales
justement pour travailler là dessus je
le dis clairement c'est la première
priorité un dernier mot sané ciani
rapidement il ya la proposition de loi
pour encadrer le recours au cabinet de
conseil qui nous avait été présenté par
l'unanimité des sénateurs devraient être
examinés dans une niche parlementaire au
mois d'octobre est ce que vous le
soutiendrez quand même moi en tout cas
j'ai reçu la sénatrice bazin sénateurs
la c29 à celle ci fardeau les sénateurs
bazin pour leur indiquer que j'avais la
volonté de travailler avec eux et
d'aboutir ensemble à renforcer notre
cadre de contrôle j'ai d'ailleurs pris
des dispositions pour renouveler
renforcer l'accord cadre de l'état pour
recourir à des prestations de conseil
renouvelé qu'on a fait ça avant l'été et
un appel d'offres est en cours sera
achevé à la fin de l'année lorsqu'on a
fait une première étape pour pouvoir
renforcer à la fois sur l'encadrement
des montants les mesures de déontologie
la transparence aussi du travail qui est
fait dans les prestations de conseil le
meilleur encadrement des données issues
des prestations de conseil tout ça ce
sont les sujets que les sénatrices et
les sénateurs avaient mis sur la table
dans le cadre de la commission
sénatoriale faisait déjà largement
repris et je suis prêt à avancer avec
eux pour aboutir et renforcer l'état moi
ce qui m'importe c'est de renforcer
l'état je vois ce sont des sujets sur
lequel là aussi voyais on parlait de
marine le pen tout à l'heure les
populistes s'en empare assez facilement
parce que eux ce qui les intéresse c'est
la polémique mais dès lors qu'on a réglé
le sujet il ya plus personne au bout du
fil maintenant on va continuer à avancer
avec des sénateurs et sénatrices qui ont
envie de renforcer l'état je crois que
c'est le cas des sénateurs est celle ci
ont déposé cette ppl ils me trouveront
avec eux pour pouvoir avancer ensemble
merci beaucoup la nécessité d'avoir été
avec nous merci fabrice redon
[Musique]